recently two girls in this hate group
went on a podcast of my friends
um and I have two two friends one did
recruiting for us for a little bit his
name is Eddie and Daley and they both um
are on the show The domino effect and
you guys can look up this actual podcast
and these girls went on this podcast and
were just talking [__] about me for an
hour and again don't really care about
my life and what happened was I I saw
that they attacked Auntie Jenny which is
kind of like this um woman that I feel
like I'm like been taken under her wing
and I just love her
um she's like in her 50s and she's my
talent I'm sure you've seen her on the
show and she's just like literally so
lovely basically they were saying she's
so rude and you guys can come for me
that's fine I sign up for this and I
guess she does too by coming on the show
but don't come for Auntie Jenny though I
was like a line has been crossed